こんにちは はじめしゃちょーと
こんにちｈ…
ｳｯ
伝説のサイコロを見つけました
なんか 5つあって
このサイコロが
はい
で 5つになんか言葉が 書いてあります
ほう
4種類ありまして
はい
これには 「私」と「あなた」と書いてあ ります
ほう
で、もう1つが
動詞が書いてあると…www
はい...w
「舐める」やらね…
[よっち] ヤバくないですか…[はじめ] 吸う、揉む、噛む
叩くとかね
〈よっち〉なるほど
動詞が書いてあるやつが
〈よっち〉はい
もう1つが…
名詞が書いてあります
名詞…
まぁ その動詞で、どこをどうするか
あぁ～なるほど
唇とか
乳とか...
やばくないっすかこれ...
尻！
う～わっ…
尻舐めるって ヤバくない!?
ヤバい…ヤバい!!
こう、いろいろ書いてあるんですけども
もう1つのサイコロには
副詞が書いてあります
ちょっと「ナニナニ」するとか
激しく「ナニナニ」する…
〈よっち〉激しく…
という感じでですね
サイコロ5つあるんですよ
で、誰が誰に何をどのようにするかっていう
ということはもう この空間に
「僕」と「はじめ」さん しか
居ない…ですから
だって、もう女性とやったらもうあれでしょ？
「乳」を「激しく」「揉む」で
勝ちでしょだって...w
アハハハハハｗｗｗｗｗ
ということは できないんですよ
できないんで ちょっとね、今回は
「よっち」とやっていこうと思います!
まぁ…イチバン 当たりは
「乳」を「激しく」揉むだよね
そうですｎｗｗｗ
まぁ なんで たとえば
例を出すと…
「私」「あなた」「唇」「激しく」「噛む」だったら
「私」が「あなた」の「唇」を…
「激しく」噛まなきゃいけない
こういうことですよね？
ヤバいな…大丈夫かな…
ねぇ 気持ち悪い… これホントに
気分を害される方も いると思うので
皆さん 視聴すじゅするしゅｓｓｓ...
視聴しゅるす
ｳﾌﾌ
なん、なんで言えないんですか…
わ～～～！！！！！！！！！！
視聴する際は
食事中とか、苦手な方は
見ないようにしてください
2回、2回で4回やりましょ
あ、そうですね(ぴーー)
最初はグー
ジャンケン ポイッ!!
後攻いきましょう
先、嫌だなぁ…
先も、嫌だなぁ…
ただ、ただ「私」「私」ってあるから
は：そうすれば自分自身の尻を吸うとかね、
よ：叩くとかｗ
一同：あっははｗｗｗ
よ：もバカじゃないですかW
は：じゃよっちさん一発目よろしくお願いしますｗ
よ：任せてください。
は：一個ずつ投げようかじゃあ
よ：一個ずつｗ
よ：まずいきやす
よ：誰が...？
は：俺がぁぁぁ！！！？
よ：ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
よ：はじめさんが　は：おれが！？
よ：じゃあ「あなた」「あなた」だったら
よ：はじめさんがw　は：おれが...w
よ：ｗｗｗｗ
は：待ってこれ大事だよ！？
よ：これ大事っすねｗ
よ：じゃはじめさんが
よ：じゃどっちに？
一同：ああああ！！！
は：俺か！×2
は：おっけおっけおっけ！
一同：耳！
よ：あ、耳！
よ：耳を？
よ：どうするのかなぁ？
一同：激しく！
よ：さあ動詞です！次　はい
一同：揉む！
よかったーーーよかったよかった
〈はじめ〉まぁ　いいスタートですね　いいスタートいいスタート
あなたがあなたの耳↗を激しく揉む↘と
よ：はい、そうです。
フォフォフォフォフォ　（カサカサカサ）（・・・）
男同士でやるから気持ち悪いけど
これ女の子とやったらマジもう
じゃあ次はわたくしがふりましょう
激しく叩かせたいな
鼓膜破かせたい
うわぁーーこれなんとも言えねぇなぁーー
あなたがあなたの耳をチョット揉むと
〈よっち〉なるほど
ではどうぞ
わっばっば
そろそろいやな予感がしてくるね
〈よっち〉そろっそろ
やっぱりはじめさんの、、
乳首を激しくかみたいっすもん
さぁいきましょう
〈はじめ〉ア゛ァ゛ァ゛ァ゛ァ゛ァ゛ァ゛ァ゛ァ゛
やっときたぁぁ
ヤバイ（ガクブル）
これはヤバイぞいやな予感がしてきた
ナニをするかちょっと良いですかじゃあ
吸うの？ヤバイよこれよっち
〈よっち〉どこ吸うかな
やらかしてるよこれ
マジ　ケツとかっだたら俺ほんとに
多分何か変な性病にかかるよ　二人で
いやぁ　こっちでしょ
〈よっち〉あーなるほど
さぁ　どこをやさしく吸うかですよぉ
〈よっち〉乳ィィィィィィィ　ハッハァ　ハァァァァア////
〈よっち〉ハァァァア
〈よっち〉ハァァハ
〈よっち〉ハァァ
ヤバ　これぇ
はいとゆうわけで今のやつはですねええと
〈よっち〉私があなたの乳↗をやさしく
吸うゥゥゥゥゥゥゥウッ
f*ck you
〈よっち〉ディヒ　ちょっとまって
エへェもう　ほんとにこれマジでホモビデオだからね
fc2とか転載される可能性あるよ
よしこぉぉぉい
〈よっち〉それじゃあいきます
うわぁぁぁぁやだなぁぁぁぁ
あぁぁやだほんっとにやだ　きも
〈よっち〉ちょっと上向いてください
やだぁぁぁ
あぁぁぁぁぁ
やだぁぁぁはぁぁ
ククグゥゥゥ
ほんとにやだ
はいはいじゃあ失礼します
ねぇちょっと
〈二人〉ハッハッハッハッハァ
〈よっち〉もう覚悟してください
あぁ分かった分かった
じゃあすぐして
〈よっち〉何秒ですか？
いやぁやさしく吸って
スワっとｗｗ
〈よっち〉スワっとｗｗ？
早く早くしよ
ねぇぇ　ほんとにいやだぁぁぁぁ
〈よっち〉手が邪魔なんですよ
デッヒトゥ
ねぇ　ちょっとまって
アァァァッハッハッハッハ
はいとゆうわけでいよいよラストでございます
いやぁもう　今の越すやつないよ多分
〈よっち〉もうヤバイですね
ほしいなヤバイやつが
いきます
あぁぁこれヤバイ
ほんとに男とやるとこんな気持ち悪いことになりますけど
男女でやったらね　とんでもないことになるんで
ぜひね　これ使う時は注意して楽しんでみてくださいっ
ではっ
〈よっち〉ではっ
いきましょう
〈よっち〉お願いします
〈よっち〉アァァァァァァァァァァンン/////
た～～たらりらら～りらら～らりらりら～ら～♪
らりりらりらりら～ら～
ていらりりら～ら～
ちらり～り～ら～ら～
ちらり～り～ら～ら
ぺぺぺぺ！！！